he might look like the British Foreign
Secretary but drew Gordon is decidedly
anti brexit he's campaigning with other
Londoners to keep Britain in the
European Union his goal have another
referendum and put the question again to
sue the British people leave one the
previous referendum on the basis of on
the basis of lies told by leave campaign
most of the people in this group
including Gareth Williams and IT
consultant only got involved in the
issue after last year's referendum now
he's out three times a week you're
basically saying look we're here we're
not going away you know our voice still
counts it's the process isn't over it's
still going to be nearly another two
years but this group of activists is
hardly representative of the wider
public and it hasn't been easy winning
people over opinion polls suggest most
Brits who voted to leave the EU last
June haven't changed their mind there
isn't any evidence of any clear major
significant change in the balance of
opinion this is a country that divided
over brexit and this is a country that
still divided over brexit 12 months
later voters and Rumford on the eastern
outskirts of London overwhelmingly
favored brexit in last year's vote Tony
Geary is just as NTEU now as he was then
there's too many people in this country
don't matter what color what race what
size they are there's so many people and
we've got to stop more people coming in
because we will sink halting immigration
seems more important than the possible
economic consequences of Britain's
leaving the EU some traders are already
dealing with higher wholesale prices
I've lost that slightly but in the
longer run I think it's for the benefit
of the country and for me as a business
but even some brexit ears and Romford
are getting anxious about the Prime
Minister's negotiating tactics it's just
gonna be a hard fight ain't gonna be
easier as I fall and don't feature has
to go by the situation no
till we pull out she's got to be a
little bit softer but not too soft the
front lines have not shifted that much
but the battle over Europe is far from
over
[Music]